>> Bret: AS SPECULATION GROWS
OVER WHETHER THE U.S. WILL DROP
OUT OF THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL,
THERE IS A RENEWED PRESSURE
TONIGHT TO BRING HOME SEVERAL
AMERICANS HELD PRISONER IN THE
ISLAMIC REPUBLIC.
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON TELLS
US WHERE THINGS STAND TONIGHT
FROM THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> GOOD EVENING.
THE FAMILIES OF AMERICANS
DETAINED IN IRAN SAY THEY HOPE
THIS REPRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE WANTS
CHANGES TO BE AROUND POLICY BY
MAY 12.
IF NOT, HE SAYS HE'S GOING TO
WITHDRAW THE UNITED STATES FROM
THE IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
THE WIFE OF ONE DETAINEE IN IRAN
SAYS SHE HOPES THE SURROUNDING
DISCUSSION, THOUGH SURROUNDING
THE IRAN NUCLEAR AGREEMENT WILL
PROVIDE AN OPENING FOR THE U.S.
TO BRING ONE OF ITS OWN HOME.
>> MR. PRESIDENT, PLEASE HELP
US.
PLEASE SAVE OUR FAMILY.
PLEASE BRING MY HUSBAND'S CASE
INTO ANY NEGOTIATION ON IRAN.
I PUT A LOG OF HOPE -- I PUT A
LOT OF HOPE IN IT AND WE ARE
COUNTING ON YOU.
>> HER HUSBAND IS A GRADUATE
STUDENT AT PRINCETON.
AUTHORITIES ARRESTED HIM NEARLY
A YEAR AND HALF AGO IN IRAN
RESEARCHING HIS PhD.
IN THE IRANIAN COURT SENTENCED
HIM TO TEN YEARS IN PRISON FOR
SPYING UNDER THE COVER RESEARCH.
A SENIOR STATE DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL TRAVELED TO EUROPE TO
MEET WITH LEADERS TO PUSH THEM
TO AGREE TO STRICTER PENALTIES
AGAINST IRAN.
OFFICIALS SAY WHILE IN EUROPE,
THEY ALSO MET WITH
REPRESENTATIVES FROM HER IRAN
AND DEMANDED THEY RELEASE THE
AMERICANS THEY ARE HOLDING.
THE U.S. WILL ENGAGE IN MORE
DISCUSSION UNTIL THAT MAY 12
DEADLINE.
SHE SAYS SHE HOPES IT PROVIDES
AN OPPORTUNITY AT A GREATER
CHANCE THAT SHE WILL SEE HER
HUSBAND AGAIN SOON, AND THEIR
5-YEAR-OLD SON WILL SEE THEIR
FATHER.
>> I'M SO SCARED AND I FEAR MORE
AND MORE FOR HIS SAFETY.
I HOPE OUR GOVERNMENT AND MR.
MR. TRUMP CAN GIVE HIM HOPE I
CAN MAKE OUR FAMILY WHOLE AGAIN.
>> STATE DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL
SAYS THE UNITED STATES DISCUSSES
THOSE AMERICANS DETAINED IN IRAN
AND THEY SAY IT'S THE TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR THEY LIKE TO ADDRESS
AND WANT TO ADDRESS.
THE CAPTURE OF AMERICANS WHO
WERE THERE, BALLISTIC MISSILE
TESTING, AND AGGRESSION ACROSS